welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting a discussion
a discussion that will feature some
special guests that we will tell you
about very shortly I will not be
adopting this no late night DJ jazz
voicings it's a little bit but it's just
to ease you back in because this is the
own this is only the second biscuit well
we're coming easing back into this you
know getting getting my my butt grooves
back in my ear biscuits seat can you
just give me a little bit of jazz voice
just for a little bit just for my own
sake just a little bit just a little bit
of this it's guys I just I just don't
have quite the tone for it well just
drop it down a little bit I'll sit down
lower the Gusev a little dropped drop it
down just a lot of the goos a little bit
we've got some if your or the goozle a
little bit I saw like a an NBA
telestrator operate okay that's a
different thing for another time okay
we're given a full court for us tonight
bazinga
I think that's a sitcom phrase yes
second biscuit getting our very get now
but grooves in the seat man you can hear
us you could see this well you know some
people can hear some people can see some
people can do both some people are
watching on mute that's your thing
I don't care do it I mean sometimes I
watch videos with my eyes closed just to
see if it would have been better as a
podcast you know it's like I know the
feeling with this ski fail video montage
I'm watching be better if it was just
the audio I can safely say not it's just
like a lot of like soft snow moving and
then like like a painful
yeah which it could it be it could be
anything I would venture to say that if
I played you a ski accident compilation
what you call it montage montage ski
mishap montage
I'm thinking and I didn't tell you what
it was there's like there's 17 different
things that you would guess that it was
anywhere you would get to skiing this we
just came up with an episode of gee no
we did we just gave over the new GMM
episode right what are we gonna cut what
are we gonna some nail it though yes is
it gonna be like a black thumb nailing
is guest:that montage
guess guess guess that montage guess
that video just by listening to the town
what compilation am i watching now the
gallium challenge yeah I would say the
game experiment because maybe people
will think that the rapper the game is
it was a new video by him it will get
more clicks he's not he's not that hot
right now really wicked the game's not
honey we could have the game on the show
you think the game would come on this
let's have this show our show the other
show okay the game if you're watching or
if some of your some of your people are
watching you're invited on good mythical
morning or this show to listen to videos
and guess what they are along with us
the game with the game yeah but we're
not gonna make it a requirement because
if you're if you're not if you like
you're like if you got cold feet you
don't want to come on the show we're
gonna wait for a certain amount of time
but then we're just gonna do it the game
does have circulation issues he does how
do you know him he raps about it no he
does I can't feel my toes no he doesn't
okay my true my my ring toe on my left
foot I can't feel it there's medication
for that got tattoos on my face you just
stand up more okay we're gonna have it
into my conversation today not just with
the two of us but we're bringing in some
special guests now we told you that
we're gonna do things a little bit
different in season three I'm excited
about this this one we didn't do this
kind of thing ever before on an ear
biscuit we're bringing in a couple of
people who are mythical crew members
they work here at mythical entertainment
and they're both single and we have been
told that they both use the dating apps
well you know at lunch we hang out as a
family as a mythical family and you know
things pop up in conversation someone
might be on their phone and you might
see them swiping but like what you
swiping
oh I'm just swiping somebody on a
swipeable relationship dating
application right and I'm like what is
that I don't understand can you tell me
about it and then it just opens up a
world of yeah anecdotal evidence that I
am a dinosaur right we're so out of
touch with this we thought it'd be great
to sit down and have a conversation find
out what it's like to date in Los
Angeles in one of the largest cities in
the world mm-hmm using modern dating
apps so Lizzy and Saagar agreed to hang
out with us and talk about it and learn
us some things we had a great
conversation we think you'll enjoy it
here it is say a little something make
sure it feels good check check one two
hello hey there guys yeah yeah that's
nice that's real good and Lizzy yes I'm
here as well yeah thank you you can see
that oh wow now did you just literally
get a match on tinder on your watch I
did because it's the future and my watch
is also my phone I have an Apple watch
and I looked down and I had a tinder
match but what does it say like if I if
I were to see it it's gone I don't know
it's like it's just like when you get a
push notification on your phone except
it just pops up right there yeah you
both you have a match you both have
Apple watches oh we planned this yeah it
was an expensive commitment guess how
many people how many people here in the
office have Apple watches three Casey
has one yeah that's it what are the
chances that we got this shouldn't be
about dating this should be about the
Apple watch less about that this
shouldn't be about statistics so I don't
know what your chances of anything are
right I'm excited to have this
conversation because I feel like it's
gonna be like two aliens who are
visiting the planet of dating in the
digital age in Los Angeles hmm who have
never done that and never will do
well I have a date night man speak for
yourself you have it you have a date
night it has nothing to do with this
well I mean but it's as close as I've
gotten you you simulate dating with your
wife which is a very healthy thing and I
I do that too I should do it more often
but it has nothing to do with what we as
aliens visiting your world are gonna
learn tonight but there are some times
when I like if I if we're at a
restaurant and I come back from the
bathroom and and I come up to my wife I
treat her like I'm meeting her for the
first time and I'm like excuse me is
anyone sitting here
yeah I only role play at restaurants
joggers strictly it's just at
restaurants I simulate a date with my
wife no it's not something date when
you're married yes absolutely it's
because they're yeah yeah yeah because
there are things at stake but they're
totally different things
it's that's the quality of your
relationship that's the same subject to
a commitment that's been made almost 17
years earlier yeah I think because
that's what we're that we want to get to
the bottom of is not the dates that are
taking a relationship to the next level
so to speak I mean what we might hear
about some of those but just the process
because currently you're both single
right yeah yeah okay not currently in a
relationship with anybody and you're not
dating each other you're just coworkers
right and we just say we ask you both
independently to be on here separately
because by the end of this people are
and it's just you know why do people
just because you're sitting next to each
other and you were talking about dating
you don't have to date that out of the
way you've already made it awkward I
don't want to see any comments about
that yes yes it's too easy
no that is how it works so if you sit
near someone you're both wearing Apple
watches if you do have to date them well
it doesn't immediately assume that you
know we're together yeah well they start
they start our inking up right the the
watches starts syncing up one more time
they spend together Yeah right lady
when when I got married
not not started dating my wife or any
other person that I dated before her
which is just a handful of people a
handful texting didn't exist guys I mean
we are we're I mean we're we're like a
no no it did but it was like government
people did it
the military was texting government
dating I think I think the military was
texting like in the 70s that's my theory
so I think that military dating has
probably been like this for a long time
but we're not in the military never
tried to be I you know I support the
military I think the veteran should be
supported supported but I got curly in
the military's leg guys can we talk
about the Apple watch link has link is
currently wearing a military-style
jacket but that's just coincidental but
no yeah I remember I bought a cell phone
for my wife when we were what she wasn't
my wife yet we just got engaged
and it was our first cellphones that was
the first cell phone I ever had was when
I was engaged in my wife and I remember
calling her on it it was like so weird
I'm like talking on a phone in my car to
you like that's how it was so yeah I
think I was 13 when I got a selfie I rub
that in remember but now you're dating
and you're using technology that wasn't
at our disposal how do you do it
how are you dating people like step one
how do you do it so step one most of
these apps are linked to your Facebook
so you gotta have a Facebook account
they use they use the pictures from
there they use like the about me from
their injuries yeah you can change all
that though it's like that's that's
that's the qualification you make sure
you're not a robot or a serial killer or
like it you could be a serial killer and
have a Facebook tinder works that way
yeah yeah most of these hooks into your
Facebook yes wasn't it what's the first
dating app that you used to actually get
a date
hinge is that still around I don't know
I think so
hinge it it was this is like probably
two years ago it it matched you with
mutual friends so like you had to had a
mutual friend or someone to pop up
through Facebook yes through Facebook
and so I did that one and I ended up
dating someone off of that for a couple
of months so what would what were the
mechanics of hinge like I mean was there
swiping was there I was hinging think so
like you know what I can't remember but
since tinder came out I think they all
kind of copied the like left is no right
as yes idea they didn't patent that no
everybody did it is the hinge the person
that you each share is that what the
hinges yeah I think so that well that's
how relationships got started in middle
school it was always there was always a
mutual friend so I that totally makes
sense to me
yeah and how did that how did that work
out um he was very nice but what is it
wasn't it like text conversation within
the hinge yes so the way all them work
is that you match with someone and then
with the exception of bumble generally
either person can initiate the
conversation and then once you have you
talked to them for a little bit I mean
depends on the person but I usually want
to talk to them enough to make sure
they're not a psycho and then you all
text though all text and then you can
exchange actual phone numbers and then
move off the app from there and like you
can call them you can text them and then
agree to meet up do you use them always
and this is a question for both of you
if there is a match
do you always have a vocal phone call
before meeting them yeah before no I
missed phone calls are weird right
I have before but you know like what I
find phone calls on it freising I had it
I had a hunch hunch though but phone
calls are uncomfortable yeah for sure
but you gotta hear their voice I feel
like a voice is an important thing so
what are you like so you got recordings
no no like oh that's oxidants yeah like
I'll have one
call before meeting them and all you
usually - yeah that's usually like and
it won't be like a like a full
conversation you'll just call and just
not say anything and just listen for
them to say I'll start 67 this'll exist
I don't know 6 9 whatever where it's
like anonymous like that okay now I just
heard your voice meet me at the coffee
shop no I I usually talk to them like
I'll call them or they'll call me to
make the plan like so what are you doing
you want to you want to go here whatever
Oh something like but it's not like you
know like you let me let's get to know
each other better over the phone it's
all logistics it's it's just as quick as
possible to make sure that you can
understand them yeah audibly but have
you ever had gotten on the phone and it
was like a weird voice you're like shut
it down I didn't shut it down I was nice
about it but I didn't talk to him what
was the voice like was it husky it was
like it was just a you know like it
didn't match their face it was it was
very it was very you thought that
getting catfished no it was like really
it was a man's voice deep voice okay it
wasn't a man have deep voice I know but
it was like you know comparable to mine
there's got to be a difference it just
wasn't what you wanted it oh boy yeah
yeah yeah that's a criteria what I want
to like it's a part of the person here
first thing in the morning you know oh
you're thinking about okay you're
thinking about long-term yeah I mean I
do when I'm on these apps I don't want
to just go on dates you know I want to
look for someone I want to find someone
that I want to spend the rest of my life
with and so you know you gotta factor in
all these little details because for us
it was I mean I get I'm sure I mean when
online dating started happening I mean
before phones when it was over the
internet that was for people who were
scared of people it was yeah it was it
was something that if you did it you
wouldn't admit to it and then if it when
it worked out and you know you were
dating you were introducing other people
you would come up with an
another thing to say this is based on
like friends experiences that you know
they would come up with another thing to
say and then I would be like but they
met on the internet was online dating
before before these days so when you
guys OkCupid I think we never did any of
that okay keep it for a little bit
actually I do
I went on one date using okay but it
wasn't okay at first to go on the
OkCupid it was like like like a recluse
or you're you're weird or desperate or
you're into second life already right
you might as well just continue the
second life right the second life of
dating yeah of something that was at
least my perception and I think in the
majority of people on earth that I cared
about yeah I feel like it used to be
like embarrassing yeah right when I went
in der first came out I didn't have a
girlfriend at this time between now and
then I was in a relationship for two and
a half years but I remember tinder first
came out and I was at this Thanksgiving
party it was when I first moved to LA so
I didn't know many people and there was
this couple there and they said that
they met on tinder and tinder was like
maybe six seven months old by that time
and they had been together for four or
five months and when they said it they
said it in that tone that there'll
apologetics yeah yeah yeah you get weird
we met on tinder but I thought it was so
gamified that it kind of cheapened the
cheapened it yeah I mean I I don't think
there's a stigma now some people I think
it does still bother and they actually
will still like try and make something
up about meeting through mutual friends
but for the most part I don't think
people care and I I had a similar thing
where I was also in a long-term
relationship when tinder came out and
then when I got out of that relationship
that's actually the first time that I
started using all these apps and it was
it was a totally different thing because
I still had the idea of online dating in
my head being something kind of weird
and then it it does open a door and it's
almost here's the bad thing about it
mm-hmm
there's too many options so
point of people of people it's not like
you're just meeting mutual friends and
you know it there's hundreds of people
and it's weird because you feel like I
could keep going like you know it there
there isn't the same stakes about
connecting with one person like a small
town though that's probably not the case
no right because this yeah what so you
can set the radius to a certain amount
yeah anywhere from one to a hundred
mine is small because I will not date
someone on the west side right and I
think that's something that I had
absolutely no concept of before moving
to LA that the size of Los Angeles not
just the size but it is large but it's
also very difficult to get around
friends you make when somebody lives on
the west side it's like dating somebody
in South Carolina yeah and so you work
what do you set you're ready to say oh I
think it's like I think it's less than I
think it's a game eight miles that's a
long ways well not really
yeah get up to Santa Clarita Santa
Clarita from my house eight my and
you'll never make it back right you
don't want to meet one of those folks
out there tell me about the first person
that you went out on a physical date
with through an app I remember and it
was on a different app called coffee
meets bagel
are you there the bagel I think well I
don't know it might be up to your own
interpretation of that okay but it was
that is this like a racial thing
what no well I don't know I didn't I
what does it mean
I don't know interracial dating site no
I think it's just like a it's like a
meet-cute thing it's like oh let's get
coffee and a bagel meet coffee meet
bagel I don't know it seemed safe with
coffee meets bagel you only get like one
swipe per day absolutely they send you
one person a day Oh
so you got to really think about it yeah
this person is also a mutual you guys
have a mutual friend
and it doesn't tell you who the mutual
friend is unless you match yeah and then
you're right
it's a silhouette at first and then it
shows so you're matching on this person
without a picture without knowing the
mutual connection the picture oh the
silhouette of the connecting person yes
so what what did you do you remember
what you matched based off of what was
the conversation like let's use it as a
quick case study I mean always if the
profile has less information that's
better and if they're funny I mean
that's the thing it's just if I do
remember that this guy was funny yeah I
mean he was he was off sort of offbeat
and funny in a bagel kind of way in a
bagel kind of way yeah I went to a 90's
themed Christmas party with him oh cool
yeah that was their first date yeah
actually I think that was so he invited
you to a party mm-hmm yeah it was well
here's the first clue it was something
he was promoting so he was actually
working this thing which I didn't
realize and got paid for you to come to
something I think so yeah but I had a
great Christmas sweater but you didn't
so he was like come to this party that
I'm working yeah that's a little weird
right yeah yeah oh no he was weird for
sure
so you met him there how did it happen I
just met him I liked cuz you know what
they look like and it's awkward and you
like walk into the bar and you pick the
person you know I don't know oh I'm
sorry
I'll explain it to you you walk in you
pick the person that looks closest to
the pictures you've seen and then you
awkwardly walk up to them and because
sometimes they don't look like the
picture I would say most of the time
right no sometimes they do yeah but
people give their best angle that you
know the 30-degree angle and looking for
sure that myspace angle I think I look
like my pictures I will say that I made
an effort to not put the best pictures
of me on mine because I'd rather be a
pleasant surprise when I walk in as
opposed to Adam that's a smart strategy
and you know what I want to hear more
about how you optimize your profile but
we're gonna take a short break to let
you know that we have grooming products
oh yeah
speaking of dating look at this these
guys you're gonna each have to eat one
of these in its entirety we've got links
link you can get a lot of Beard link
yeah I know is that I didn't put any on
today
I've actually haven't used this I want
to try give a ringing endorsement I've
actually used this and it's amazing
though so if you are just listening what
soccer has holding in his hand is my
beard oil
Rhett's beard oil I'm holding my hand
Retin links mythical pomade and Link
what are you hold in your hand
Mike peculiarly perfect peanut butter
peppermint a lip balm available only and
our still now all these things started
in Amazon so not just as jokes you know
we didn't ever think that we were
actually gonna make this stuff but
they're all realities now and they're
all available for purchase and sagres
finding out just how amazing is and he's
got one heck of a beard I gotta admit
I'm a little intimidated by it I think I
made that clear up when he was on good
mythical more how's it holding up this
is really good you like it yeah I like
it a lot it's the highest quality stuff
man and this pomade you got to work some
of the head on it not Curt nut right now
well you can smell it if you want to
smell that describe the scent while
Lizzy listens I smelled the beard oil -
it smelled great smells like air product
it's clean
it doesn't read like a high quality hair
product brisk for sure subtle briskness
smells like a really good shampoo
okay that stays in your hair that's good
I'll go with that yeah all right yeah
that's it Rhett link mythical pomade
smells like a really good shampoo all
these products available at rent link on
flash store and also Amazon not the
river the website okay amazing the
profile so your pictures are you think
authentic real true to life sagar what's
your what's your thing cuz you could you
like you like decorate your beard for
the holidays and stuff like that you
know yeah I always put like one or two
of those photos just cuz like hey I'm
fun look at me
and then my beard is fun at least yeah
yeah oh that's good though thought that
would like that's a good sign if
somebody has a sense of humor and it
puts things in their beards that's good
yeah and then I'll put like just like
one I keep my photos at like three three
or four photos so I'll put like two of
those and then one of them will be like
a miniature horse or something yeah and
you put something that's not you you can
I don't but you can then I like to have
one photo where I might be like with a
couple of friends or something cuz it
kind of shows like your social you know
you go out you have fun this is my
ex-girlfriend yeah yeah those aren't
good though there are a lot of those oh
really like with another person yeah
there yeah there are a lot of like you
know a guy and a girl together or
whatever in them with you man what is
that that's great well there's two
different scenarios that could okay yeah
I think I understand one yeah I don't
know the other lack of judgment yeah
sounds like either one yeah or or they
you know they forgot to take that photo
off their Facebook profile yeah oh yeah
cuz it's connected to Facebook so it
brings it in right can we keep going
through this case study here so you meet
this guy and you yet you had to walk up
to him at the party he was throwing yeah
and you're like I think you're the guy
from the photo yeah I'm gonna have an
opening salvo which cannot not be
awkward in some way I mean it's no it's
definitely awkward especially if you've
never had a phone conversation with the
guy you just had text yeah also I'm an
incredibly awkward person so like it's
gonna be uncomfortable when I meet
someone off in one of these apps and how
did it go what do you remember about it
I remember it being very fun actually he
was I mean it that was a good experience
I haven't had particularly bad
experiences to be honest I guess because
I am particular about who I would like
to actually meet but it was fine so what
how are you in valuating the profile
though like how do you make this
decision because it's go so Kay he's
cute okay check that box actually don't
I don't know I I don't trust
particularly attractive people so in
general I okay I think I that's less
important to me then if you have
something what is your standard what do
you mean we're not standard listen
what is your what's your threshold
what's your criteria want to know how
ugly did it have to be yeah like when is
somebody too attractive and then went to
somebody not attractive enough for you
what's your Goldilocks area if
somebody's in better shape than I am
that's probably a no oh really yeah so
okay so like if there's like a abs photo
or something yeah you don't want to see
visible ABS I don't like particularly
like visible abs I'm a weird case you
probably shouldn't I'm not gonna be most
varied okay do I do I like a little a
little bit like you know I like some
meat on the bones and they're all sort
of a burly like a like a nice average
looking nice person look nice you know
pictures are there gifs no just pictures
I think now you can in like the
messaging aspect of it you can send gifs
yeah you can right I remember you can
see how we got everybody to say Jeff
there yeah I could just as easily got
everybody's like gifts I think I would
have said gifs you would have but I
don't know the man told me to say Jeff
so you can't put videos on there isn't
like hi I'm Lauren and no but you know
what people do link to their instagrams
yes that's helpful yeah actually all
types of things including hiring okay
and saga what about you like are you
looking for somebody's not too
attractive like this is a lot like
hiring I mean when you when you hire
people you look at all the same stuffs
like well do they what type of pictures
do they put on their stuff I mean there
are moments you know over let's see
somebody they're like that person's so
attractive they've got to be evil in
some way yeah no I'm saying yeah I
definitely see that crazy scale yeah
right yeah yeah I feel like it is kind
of like an interview you know you can go
through their Instagram you see first of
all you see how many followers they have
oh oh
really you do that listen you do that no
I don't even thought about that okay I'm
gonna have too many and yeah I don't
want them to have like a hundred
thousand cuz in this you don't want them
to be a personality right right okay
because usually if they are they won't
like they won't like me as much you know
that they just don't like I mean not
just me but like they're the kind of
people they're on Instagram they're they
would like to get matched and they don't
necessarily respond to your messages
okay okay so now that you said that's
the threshold of 100,000 followers isn't
there an app that is like some elite
riah
see okay and you're not supposed to talk
about this right like this is the I read
an article by this this is the dating
app that you're not supposed to talk
about so let's talk about it riah how do
you spell that
our aya and this is like there's a
threshold for social media following you
basically have to be like a semi
celebrity and up to be on this thing
yeah we have you have to apply for it
and and then like it takes four weeks or
something for them to go through it have
you heard back yet but then are you
stuck with other sort of pseudo
celebrities yes you're so everybody is
like has X amount of followers plus or
yeah you don't even have to have like
10,000 followers you could just be you
know some actor or someone that has an
established career that just doesn't
have a following it sounds like a guy at
the door of a club who's like you could
come in and then somebody skipping the
line yeah because of the shoes they have
on yeah I was once with you were there
you may have already forgotten this but
we're not gonna mention any names but we
were by that Rhett mean don't mention a
new name we were with a fellow youtuber
who was a youtuber with a very large
following and he or she I won't even say
he or she it's a dude right was was on
this app and had just just gotten
accepted and was like
the people that they were being matched
with and the impression I got from this
person was I wasn't part I don't
remember any of this but that people
could pay large amounts of money so I
don't know if I think there's another
one if this not riah these people could
pay a large amount of money to just
regular people could pay a larger to
live in large amounts of money to get on
there to then reach out you didn't
PayPal information and maybe it works
you're forgetting maybe yeah but Lizzy
it's interesting because this is great
I'm glad we found this dichotomy here
because Sagar you you're applying for
this did I didn't get accept right but
no but like you that you'd like the idea
of you know you know meeting somebody
like that Lizzy that's abhorrent to you
I don't know if that was his idea I
don't know what his motivations were
well I wanted to see what was out there
I just wanted to see I just I honestly
just wanted to see the app like I wanted
to be able to log into it and see and
make it sense that about you
you know real enough no I did have I do
have a friend that is on that app and
I'm not going to say his or her name no
but she did you got to think about this
the whole time yeah she matched with one
of your friends and they were talking
for a little bit what yeah one of our
friends any one of our friends the guy
who Rhett is talking about in the car it
could be him like public friends or
private friends pretty public I guess
okay so a youtuber yeah and what have
you guys was that they just became
friends ultimately but not it wasn't it
wasn't romantic
I think that's yeah she just didn't want
to you know continue having a romantic I
don't think they ever had a romantic
relationship I think they went on a
couple of dates but nothing happened
from that and
so she was just like let's just be
friends and like I don't want to be in
your daily vlog or I don't know what it
would be well here's my assessment again
I have no clue who you're talking about
but again I don't have to worry about
this because I've been married for these
are gonna be 16 years yeah yeah and
you're gonna be 17 years I'm gonna be 16
years right that's how I remember it
when you're apart don't correct me as if
I was thinking the wrong thing you're
right though right it's you're gonna
yeah 17 yeah okay so but the idea of
being romantically involved with someone
else who is like trying to get Internet
followers that I that doesn't sound like
know that like to people who want more
Instagram followers or Internet
followers and that's the thing man
becomes pretty superficial well give me
a so if it wasn't that but give give me
a case in point give me a case study
from from your experience good or bad
you know with anyone so let's see I went
on this one date I used OkCupid and this
was like before I was in that
relationship and you know she seemed
pretty cool were chatting for a little
bit and I went out with her we went on a
date and one thing I should have done is
and like it doesn't seem that important
but it kind of is height everybody posts
their height on there and this girl she
was like four nine I think yeah and that
was like a really weird thing but she
was like so not taller than that yeah a
little bit how tall are you 511 511 okay
I don't either
there's people that are like mad that
I'm tall when I show up maybe yeah I
mean I think most people are very happy
that you're tall but I mean if people if
there's like a really short dude is
really self-conscious about that he
might be like why didn't she tell me
that she was how tall you I'm 5 9 I
people shorter than I am though well not
every guy has a problem without ever
saying there are some guys yeah oh yeah
so you felt like she you know when
you're in that sand notable quality you
know yeah it should have been part of
your power of choice to say okay you
know at least a heads up would be nice
yeah I mean like that's not she doesn't
have to you know like not everybody
posts their height on there and you you
don't have to do that obviously but like
it's nice to know if you are you know
somewhere on the on like the extreme
side of tall or short yeah it'd be nice
to know because if you're me then you
show up in your site okay now the I'm
gonna say the stupid inconsiderate thing
about wires sure well that's a good
point I'm kind of on the opposite end of
the spectrum and I don't know I don't
know if I would want people to think
that I have to probably really yeah
you're so tall I feel like it would be
alarming if you did that can't be no way
yeah I don't have to think about these
things guys I'm glad lucky you I mean if
you showed up with who's sagar showed up
with it would be like she was dating
your crotch well you know player like
you need you need yeah interesting
holding a hand that low that was a
deal-breaker for you yeah I mean like
ultimately it wasn't the deal breaker
but it was like okay I don't think this
is gonna work I like you know I I was
nice to her continued the date we were
out for like an hour and a half had
dinner and then that was it but like if
she had like if her personality was like
up here if her personality was taller
than her okay you know okay I would have
gone on another date but you know it's
just we we just weren't meshing did you
have some bad ones awkward
or fizzle out I mean just like okay we
have one and this that's it I'm bailing
definitely there were ones that were
like that oh I went to a comedy show
with a guy and that was a first date and
that was weird because when I got he
came to pick me up and when I got in the
car with him which my parents ever
listen to this they're gonna be so mad I
got in the car with someone I don't know
but we had a mutual friend I'd like to
poke in with them about about him and
everything just in case your parents are
listening just in case mom she doesn't
know what podcast is it's fine but his
friend was in the car with him and it I
immediately struck up more of a
conversation with the friends than I did
with this guy and I were both in the
backseat or something no I was in the
backseat by myself and like the friend
was in the front and it was weird and
this guy was super awkward which is
about like why he brought the friend I
think because he was cool but I ended up
like making friends with the friend and
I think it made this guy mad mmm and so
it was really weird he got but that's
the only one that was bad he got like
really quiet
don't bring a friend on a date yeah I
wouldn't talk to me but I I did I did
break up I dated someone for a big I
think two people relatively seriously
off of the apps not I mean like two to
four months but one of them was the
break-up was like way easier than any
breakup I've had that wasn't from online
dating why is that I don't know maybe
it's cause like there's an expectation
that it won't work
did you can you break up through the app
is that a function no I I called him I
was like I'm gonna do this in person you
can't unmatch but I mean we'd been
dating I had you know we had each
other's phone numbers everything and I I
met him at about a bar and I was like I
was so prepared I was like I have my
speech no it's just like I'm so busy and
I just don't have time and you're so
nice and everything well what's the real
reason like well I mean going into it I
didn't you didn't like him yeah of
course but he a lot but he really liked
you know that's the funny part of this
breakup is that when I said that I
thought he was gonna be like bummed you
had a hole you gave your whole speech
what was his speech like it was I was
like
so sorry like you know I really like you
and it's just that I'm so busy and you
do know that's never true right yes 100%
if that has ever been said to you that
has never been Oh cuz if you really like
Suzy don't break up with them yeah I'm
yeah right that's a good point I'm just
not ready for this or I did any any
excuse that is about the person just
means they just don't like you yeah
ultimately is what that's what that but
you said I really like you but okay so
yes I fibbed a little you're a great
person
yeah which may have been true great guy
I think he's a good guy but I went
through my whole speech and he was just
like okay and I was like oh and then we
ended up having a drink and like
laughing about how easy it was and then
he was like he was like yeah wow we
really had nothing in common did we and
I was like not at all like this great
you had you had a rebound relationship
with the guy who had just broken up with
a rebound like date yeah a rebound
dinner yeah oh actually I remember why I
met him in person that remember that
time we broke up a few seconds ago boy
that was fun a lot easier than we
thought
remember that time when I said I liked
you end of it were you like so
comfortable that you were like yeah we
should be no not at all I remember now
why I wanted to meet him in person and
that I wanted my water bottle back oh he
had a nice water bottle yeah those gold
ones like a swell oh that's a pricey
solid gold
well 250 bucks that's why I was like I
got to do this not over the phone but
I'm in person man so you were like
you're like you texted him you're like
meet me for a date and also can you
bring you bring my swell I'm so thirsty
I asked him to bring the water bottle
before you told him what it was about
yeah I just said okay let's get a drink
it there's something I want to talk to
you probably not I probably just said
let's get a drink in this bar and can
you bring my water this is the last time
we will ever speak I think I made him go
back to his car for the water bottle to
after I'd broken up oh wow and about
water bottle you should have been you
should have been like you start the
you're like you know I I got something I
really want to tell you about it but
first kind of like when red like stopped
for the ad break but first I'd like for
you to go get my water right it's weird
I've been on these like Muslim dating
apps lately right because you know I'm
30 years old and I'm starting to think
you know like I should start looking
like serious and these apps are not
local so the girls that you meet on
these apps there's not enough like
Muslims in a concentrated area for K
like that so they're all like national
they're all around the US and in Canada
so like some of the girls that I met
with a lot of em are New York DC Wow
yeah just random places so that's really
hard because basically our relationship
is through text and every once in a
while you know we'll talk on the phone
or something like that or FaceTime or
something but it's so weird but you
haven't met with anybody in LA I have
but and I've met up with one of them but
also that kind of fizzled out
you know we're and so you're so you are
hmm
maintaining multiple text relationships
at this point yeah we're people that
you've met on the app yeah like three or
four and you know but I don't talk to
them everyday
it's like maybe I'll send one or two
messages a week or something okay yeah I
thought you were like like having actual
textual relationships with people and I
was I was like I feel really bad I
couldn't I couldn't like separate all of
them start having one conversation with
all of them yeah but no I couldn't do
that it would be efficient if it was a
group text it would yeah everybody's
like a bachelor but big love yeah well
no no no it's like The Bachelor yeah
yeah then you're let you kick people out
of the group Jeff
yeah every week you just kicked somebody
you're not really working out and then
you go and you have like one-on-one
chats and like and you use the rose
emoji this this is this is the reality
show no no no no the whole show is just
the screen you don't even see the people
yeah this is sold on this is a great
idea it's not even an app all the
infrastructure has been built for us on
phones yeah this is just texting and we
just put a camera we don't even do a
screen camp we just put a camera on - a
what - a phone Chris Harrison still
narrates though yeah yeah is he Muslim
it's not a requirement but okay so this
is interesting so what is the okay so
you say that you you you're doing this
ultimately you want to have a long-term
relationship right that's you're
thinking about settling down at some
point and you're assuming that this
woman is going to be a Muslim as well
yeah right and so is is this a thing
where one of these chat occasional chat
relationships will how is this gonna
lead to something like what's the
strategy how is this bachelor game
played oh man so I honestly don't know
just kind of like well let's figure out
the strategy right now let's do this
yeah so basically you know usually you
know I start talking to one of these
girls we just message back and forth a
little bit but it's just such a small
talk right there's no way I mean like
the conversations become longer you know
but then it gets like oh man I got to
respond to all five of these last
messages you know like if you're having
like like lengthy conversation is
sending you five messages at a time yeah
like you know we started like a
conversation and then
you know one of the texts might be
really long and then they responding to
each one of those parts of the
conversation through different text so I
would not be able to do this
you got a bulleted list in your texts no
no like I'm a talkie guy you know like
when it comes to text I don't like to
answer I don't like to give short
answers because you know there's
personality in long answers I want you
to know what I'm thinking and you know I
want to justify my thoughts whatever and
so they respond to those and I respond
to those and then they you know if it's
kind of not working out if it's kind of
fizzling if we disagree and a lot of
things then you'll notice those texts
will start to get shorter from both ends
and then it was just kind of die that's
how it dies out that's the window like
all that yeah yeah so you've gotten
you've got like a swollen text message
yeah and and then your terminology is so
questionable it works there and then but
that doesn't trigger a phone call I mean
it's like I don't know calls yet no a
lot of people really are uncomfortable
talking on the phone but you've got it
so you have a picture or pictures of
these ladies their profile pictures so
like the for the three or four that they
have and do you okay if you're having a
good textual relationship with someone
do you then stalk them a little bit
online find their Facebook oh for sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and they've
done the same with you assume we assume
definitely yeah okay so where's this
going is there is there one is there one
lady that is sort of setting herself
apart now right now I mean there was one
we were talking for a little while and
then I legit got really busy don't blame
us you started working here no that's no
throw us under today no that's totally
legitimate if you're not in a
relationship yet right well I I think
then once you're in a relationship and
then you start using the busy excuse
that's when I say no I get that yeah we
were uh you know busy coming up with
excuses you would have made time for him
if you really liked him
yeah so this girl and I we were texting
for a while through the the app and then
we exchanged phone numbers and then we
started texting like regular text
messages and then after about a week you
know I gave her a call and we started
talking on the phone we talked on the
phone for like an hour
did you tell her I'm about to call you
or set up an appointment like a phone
date heads up it's coming no I was just
like is it cool if I call and she was
like sure and how how calculated was
that it wasn't very calculated or just
like I'm a caller yeah feeling it like
with her it just felt really casual you
know she seemed really like just
friendly and easy to talk to you know so
uh so I called she answered and we
talked on the phone for like an hour and
then the next day she FaceTime me and
and now the flight the face is in play
I'm a face timer I would much rather
FaceTime anybody I mean especially in
this situation where you like haven't
really seen someone in motion yeah
that's great because a face in motion is
very different than the face a static
face right yeah right yeah yeah and yeah
we facetimed we were talking get a lot
of the up the nose you got to really
think about that you got such shoulders
gonna get tired but you got a really for
sure hold strong I realized through
talking to her that I would much rather
FaceTime on my macbook oh yeah no angles
not good yeah you're down here even up
here even straight it just looks it's
too close to up-close I think your whole
face is a beard yeah yeah but at least
you have the beard it's not like a
Chin's yeah that's true but none you
guys like walking up a staircase in
flesh to see the mouth space timing with
me okay so you talked to her on the
phone and then and then how did that
conversation go where did it go
what it where's this person at how far
how far away she is
in Phoenix okay that's really nice it's
like a five hour drive you can hitchhike
there and I think you could take an
ultra-light unlike one tank of gas if
you had one like a gyrocopter even yeah
you could take one of those one of those
bicycles that you that you pedal and it
has like a motor oh yeah yeah it's like
a scooter but you like be on the side of
the road you could probably get there in
a day with all one of those right big
topic what 10 miles an hour
yeah like 25 on one yeah lots options I
mean yeah you can make that work I used
one of these hoverboards so you stop
every couple of hours to charge okay so
that's company back then so the first
step was the tech second step was the
phone call and now is is there gonna be
another phone call yeah I mean we talked
for like a month so it was you know we
we became friends we were like talking
back and forth we would ask each other
for advice you know tell each other how
our days going talk about whatever I'm
going I'm having this thing you know
this problem or whatever and we were
there we were listening to each other we
would do it through FaceTime at this
point and then I started these classes
and then and then I started working this
job and you know I didn't know I was
gonna have this job I knew I was taking
those classes but this job kind of just
like came to me and was probably a good
time to tell you about our Phoenix
office express in a satellite office
mythical brain you should have asked
earlier it's very dry there it's good
for the allergies yeah you have
allergies I don't okay well yeah
wrong answer what happened with her I
just I mean what happened is he talking
about something well I just
it's like making me a little sad because
it was like she was nice yeah why he
wasn't seriously what happened yeah
there's absolutely like nothing that
happened that was like that made us stop
talking I just got really busy and she
got really busy she's uh she's a
traveling photographer so she sounds
cool she's really cool and then
and then yeah like now it's been like
three weeks since we've even sent a text
to each other and I don't know how that
happened I'm sure Los Angeles is very
photogenic traveling photographer yeah
yeah but you know what one thing that
made me kind of mad was like we were
talking about you know oh we should like
meet one of us should you know visit the
other uh-huh and I said just started
taking this class right and and so my
schedule got really crazy at night and I
couldn't miss like the class or the
rehearsals so I asked her if you know I
can fly her out here ooh on your dime
yeah I mean I would pay for it
Wow all right I'm nice guy and she said
I would only visit if I had work in LA
and that kind of made me mad oh she was
like like she didn't want to come here
if she didn't have a business reason to
come here well and that's revealing is
she going to have a business reason is
it likely to have a business reason yeah
I don't I think that's that's not the
right question there yeah well no
because I don't know I feel like I'm
just trying to see her side in this I
kind of feel like it's like well I just
want to go record and say I'm sorry man
no that's okay I'm sorry yeah we we
expected her but I see a but it is
asking a lot to be like the next step is
you just come out and hang out with me
on your dime that's like maybe she's not
ready for that because that would be
kind of saying something right obviously
that's true from her okay she doesn't
have to like to live with you I mean
yeah give us the the female perspective
on this doubling back on my perspective
that because when you said that I was
like oh that's a bummer I thought she
was cool but you know what I agree with
that because if someone is paying for me
to come out then then in my head
potentially there is some kind of
expectation as to what not that this is
the case but what is like you know owed
to them how much fun it has to be how
how much of sort of like how
entertaining you have to be I will say
that there is like a cultural difference
like like with us like she's also
Pakistani Muslim
and so you don't think that would be
weird for her than that cuz I guess if
she's thinking I would come out if I'm
working there then maybe in my head if I
were thinking that it would be I'm
coming out there because like it's it's
my diamond and my job
I don't know well you're on equal
footing yeah and then it's theirs it's
not as pressurized yeah I guess is what
you're saying the pressure of like no
the pressure like was not there you know
we yeah I'm not saying it was there I'm
saying it it might be perceived in some
waived yeah I mean like in our culture
we don't really have you know we won't
get physical it's just that's just how
it is that's true and that is what I
would be worried about so I mean if
that's not on the table then it's not as
big a deal right right yeah and it's
definitely not right you know like I
would be totally respectful I would you
know even if I had these classes or
whatever if I was busy I would you know
tell her hey you know and this is my
brother's girlfriend or you know here's
some of my friends you can hang out with
them you know let me take you out do
whatever while I'm here and then maybe
we can get a coffee tomorrow morning or
dinner at night you know I wouldn't want
to spend too much time with someone and
you're saying that she probably
understood that based on the
conversation you had that you're not
gonna share with us and you shouldn't oh
yeah but it does make me think I mean
even in a broader context you know you
think about okay is are these apps just
designed for like a hook-up culture type
situation but it does I'm gaining an
appreciation for the opposite end of the
spectrum which is it allows it it kind
of allows you to gain clarity in terms
of getting to know somebody you know I
think you you both talked about you talk
to people in what I feel is like a and
an arm's length away which is through
texts not even through a voice call but
it allows you to build more of a a
casual friendship to get to know a
person even does even before you get
like the moving face scenario
you've just got pictures profiles
whatever else you can find it's not only
being physically in the same place but
not it's just talking it's almost like
we've you know back in time in that way
it's like it's like a civil war and I'm
promised to someone far away and we're
writing letters or something like oh
well you said that I was like this is
actually worse maybe I'm sold on the
voice call now because I don't think the
text is a good indicator of what
someone's gonna be like definitely you
can't tell personality through through
reading text
also I'm a really horrible texture so
like I probably just shouldn't do that I
should just be like look I'm bad at this
here's my phone number
well is it now that this is this is the
norm right is your expectation that the
next serious relationship that you're
going to be in is going to be is going
to come from one of these apps right
what is it or is it more likely that
you're just gonna meet somebody through
a friend at a party yeah I mean all of
my I've had three genuinely serious
relationships that lasted you know more
than a year and none of them came from
any of these apps so in my experience no
but I mean it it could you know it would
certainly be nice I've always met people
through mutual friends but you're doing
the you are you doing the app thing now
I think Tinder's on your phone book
you said you re signed up for it yeah to
jog your memory about experiences you
had yeah cuz I sign up today for this
conversation but are you are you on any
other app now yeah what is your user
name for anyone listening who doesn't
work fumble across what's bumble bumble
is the one that's like a Sadie Hawkins
situation where you match with someone
and then the woman has to be the one to
speak first which I thought was a great
idea and now that I'm deeper into it I'm
like I'm so bad at this and I think I
should not do it because I completely
understand the logic right yeah and the
first time I heard about this I was like
that is a great idea because it kind of
it cuts out the creepiness increate okay
right but only guys can be
be guys are much more creepy than women
yes that is a generalization that I'm
willing to make and stand by as a man
and proud of it but I think you're out
of it I think differently about this now
because guys again
a generalization guys will take any
attention from a woman as a signal that
she will she she wants me she and she's
totally into me
so when you reach out and you're doing
it casually a lot of guys a lot of guys
are just like that's it she's into me
because she reached out she initiated
with all so you're saying it's a bad
thing but I'm saying that the concept
fire the concept might kind of fall back
on itself I don't know but in your
experience you said that you weren't you
were bad it kind of staying on top of
the the app or whatever but have you
initiated with a guy and what did you
say and then what happened I started out
trying to be like cute or funny or witty
in some way like what's your opening oh
you know I don't mr. alright let's read
this like that was I was interested in
that are you like are you trying to be
funny and you're in it I stopped trying
to be flex here's some Lizzie opening
line no they're not good actual opening
lines from Lizzie okay they all relate
to things and their profile that's what
I was trying to do is like pick
something in their profile wine like
dogs huh yeah oh you like dogs
I don't know her voice all right this is
embarrassing this is why I shouldn't be
hurt okay so really excited gentleman in
his info he says I love comedy good
music and stiff drinks Michael Keaton is
Batman now that's old me oh that's this
is quality this guy he's also rock rock
what's his user name actually I'm
looking at it it's spelled in a weird
way but I won't read it and my opening
line are you ready this is why I should
just say how is it going
I said Michael Keaton most definitely is
Batman but who's your Joker also hi
oh that's good though that's like my
best one because then if he's if he says
he's ledger
he says he's ledger which is obviously
the right answer then you have two data
points about this you know and that you
know that much more keep going then what
okay well more information was revealed
and he just read it all know it read
every minute I think I can't come on
well here why can't you see man it's
genuinely long he works in its pretty
long yes it read it read it over our
shoulder here hold on I we talked about
our worst first jobs or like our worst
sort of bad day jobs and I as you guys
know I worked on a chicken frying truck
how do you get to that though I mean
it's not that I want you to rework that
job for this I I worked at it frying
chicken like wait I like Batman and
Joker I know I have fried chicken
because I asked him about a dog in a
picture that he had and I asked his dog
he said no it's our workshop dog and I'm
an idiot so I thought and I was like oh
no you didn't mean actual shop did you
and he's like no I a prop house and then
we got talking about jobs oh no now I've
opened Twitter somehow that dog's name
was chicken-fried No but he said that he
seems good Lizzie he said now you know
what guys I'd stop talking to him but
now I think I need to talk to him again
he hold this just ended no it didn't end
I just I haven't like responded
oh that's rude I should respond what was
his last thing hold on I gotta tell you
this cuz it's good when was his last
thing
hold on he says he's a certified honey
baked ham master Glaser yeah okay are
any of those in the world are they're
not it doesn't that is not appropriate I
don't know any said did you ask me what
that was a euphemism for anything no cuz
I don't want to lead on I don't want to
do don't put the phone away okay you
want worse ones what do you want I want
yeah I'd like another that was good
I got to respond to her maybe this is
what's the last thing he said let's come
out with a response
you have a discount on a honey baked ham
I don't think he works there anymore
but I can ask where is it ended it ended
we got talking about food and I think I
was sounding like kind of a jerk talking
about Thai food but whatever right what
was your line that made you sound like a
jerk I don't know we can't honey make
that we guys talking about restaurants
in my neighborhood which I will not
reveal and mark and I and I mentioned a
restaurant
the very good Thai restaurant and I
tried to sound like I knew what I was
talking about which is always a mistake
and I said some of the best Thai food
ever legend has it the Thai ambassador
goes there when he's in town which I
think just sounds I just sound like a
jerk but whatever and then we talk about
a voice that's how he reads my text I
can tell that's how they come across so
at that point you've been like you want
to meet me there yeah I didn't do that
though cuz I'm real bad at this this is
why I should talk on the phone I said
I'm in a Korean barbecue phase and he
said nice yeah I had a sushi phase for a
bit then Thai started attempting meal
prep meals this week this week then I
didn't say anything oh how many days ago
was that I don't know I can't tell the
time let me see okay so I did I guess I
just don't what is yesterday what is the
point now though like it's like what
what is gonna happen what might this
conversation need to get to in order for
you to say let's meet a natural flow if
it seems like we're able to which we
were doing for a little bit honey baked
ham and then the difference is I am bad
she's doing a good job I'm doing a bad
job if you guys can help me formulate I
think people like wanna listen something
back right now what was the last thing
you said okay you said nice yeah I had a
sushi phase for a bit then Thai started
attempting meal prep meals this week I
think you got to say you don't have to
you have to not be in one phase at a
time you can enjoy all foods together
that's what I'm thinking
that's what I've heard what is your
objective how about how about a phase
with me how about a Lizzy phase yeah try
it you gotta throw some things out there
let you guys do this so you can see how
hard this yes your phone and respond
yeah yeah let's see how I think you guys
should go through profiles hot on this
guy you can swipe it swipe left swipe
right okay spell his name weird that's
what I said do you want to know how to
see his profile yeah okay so I don't
want to be swayed by anything except the
conversation you've had with chicken
cool yeah oh this guy's cool right see
this is like that's what I'm looking for
is it this is a guy you're interested
look at the way that's not the way he
looks at his dog okay if this is the guy
he's married well I think he's in a
wedding there he's been to a wedding
Lizzy he's a professional baseball
player no I think he just seats he sits
in baseball looks like fun
maybe that's why I look for it when
somebody looks like fun he looks like a
happy-go-lucky guys he's let his hair
down he has just a mustache and I'm very
stressed out all the time so I need
someone who is happy go lucky because I
can't be with someone who's also as
stressed out as I am that's good right
that all right how do you how do you get
back to like what I'm not gonna write
I'm horribly stressed out are you happy
go-lucky more happy-go-lucky in my life
all right wait we got to decide
something so let's do it
okay I think is the objective to move
this off of text right now we got to
take it to the next step I think it's
time to phone so what do I do
can I call you no no I think guys I
think she's got to get back into a text
flow conversation yeah then move into
you can't stop you can't go a day
without saying anything in this egg they
call me because that's how he's gonna
hear it they call me
like an emergency you can transition you
could say something like hey I'm so
sorry I didn't get on this app today but
if you want your meal prep how have you
prepped that meal yet how's that meal
prep coming I should just tell him I'm
on a podcast right now I'm talking about
you can I call you you're so smart knew
that arrabal idea but I do it yeah yeah
I'm on a podcast right now can I call
you yeah that's a great idea before I
know you can't call let's do it look you
know what let's not make him a pawn in
our entertainment
we might actually kind of like him let's
say what sagar said which is what you
should put on the app yeah say sorry I
didn't check like don't say sorry don't
apologize for something that's true but
the rest is good yeah I didn't check the
app all day so I didn't get this
notification but if you want to keep
talking here's my number oh yeah I
thought what you said how's the milk
prep coming no I didn't say that you
guys yeah you don't ask about meal prep
no I genuinely okay okay
my boss is genuinely interested in okay
so I'll just say oh man your thumbs
getting sweaty
yeah well the hands are always sweaty
perpetually clammy yeah everyone
watching should know that you sell
yourself so short on your profile sweaty
hands you got to get over this I'm
really clammy my profile I think is a
quote from 30 rock that doesn't make any
sense and has no explanation okay that's
better yeah it's heavy as the head that
eats the crayons and I don't explain
that and I don't intend to mm-hmm so
it's your idea for us to keep eating
crayons on our show so what this I'm
just gonna say sorry I'm terrible about
checking this app how's the meal prep
going yes that's it yeah and then you
just and then you just get back into
that flow and then later when you're
you're sitting there with your first
child you could be like remember that
time we were on your biscuits and we
started that conversation and well no no
he won't reckon linked me like this
there's something I gotta tell you just
watch this pot
can we just can we just can we just say
something right now I know this is
probably not gonna happen but if you end
up marrying this guy can me and Linc
perform the wedding yeah you're required
to we will do like a duel like a
tag-team wedding thing yeah you know
Kail I do you mean by perform the
wedding you mean
we will officiate it oh all right I was
thinking more like interpretive dance no
no I I would get if you end up marrying
this guy you'll become a priest I will
get ordained you can get ordained in
that what is the one that you can get
ordained like you can just fill out a
certificate - I'll do that all right and
I'll do the wedding you got to be there
- though tech team I'm gonna be there
all right I did it I sent that message
now we'll see that's so exciting
how exciting would it be if he responded
right now guys I'm never gonna hear from
him again
look you don't think so no I think so no
let's just wait I think put it out here
he looks like the kind of guy that would
respond well it pop-up if he looks nice
yeah it'll have a notification well
we'll have to check back in with you
guys to see how this is going sometime
in the future see if you've you've
married dog man what is if Phoenix lady
has come come and taking pictures of you
posing in front of things in Los Angeles
yeah
is she a portrait person yeah she does
she does portraits and wedding she kind
of does it all - she does their wedding
she's the photographer get marry Nexus
being made you have to bring her to the
wedding she takes all the pictures we
and we do it and we do the officiating
yeah that'll be wrong my hands still
have Ritz
beard oil yeah they smell great though
don't you yeah I've learned so much
thank you guys sure thanks thanks for
having us yeah your dad gets off the
phone
[Music]
well there it was I think we I think we
started potentially at least one
relationship we promise to officiate a
wedding tag-team officiate a wedding and
sagres future wife is going to take
photographs of it this is I mean this is
not the kind of thing that it just
happens
well it's unless it doesn't happen and
then we may have ended something we may
have we may have truncated something we
may have altered the future of a
relationship that would have been
amazing well no we definitely did alter
the future of a relationship here's the
thing by this is how no no no no I'm not
saying this isn't more I'm not saying
we're like all powerful or anything
weren't gonna talk in there's no I'm
gonna talk every single choice that you
make in life has it's called the
butterfly effect Ashton Kutcher knows
all about it
and then you do one little thing and
then it affects it so by bringing them
on to the podcast and discussing
relationships even if we hadn't had
gotten to that last part just by okay
bringing two single people into an
atmosphere and having them to discuss
their relationships which makes them
just think about their relationships
differently we altered intentionally or
unintentionally we altered the course of
their lives and they offered the course
of altered the course of our lives and
that's wrong we all choice of their
lives and more because we're already in
relationships and we were talking about
relationships and we're not talking
about being married for a long time
we're talking about and dating that's it
for us to satisfy some some weird
curiosity we had I mean that's what we
have altered their very life there's a
real moral question right there are we
guilty of something now yeah I mean
could we be in some future court of law
in which they evaluate your intentions
and the outcomes and the causes and
effects and they probably have the
ability to reach back in time to this
moment evaluate this podcast are we
gonna be watching this 50 years from now
in some future court and they're like
you ruin their lives well I'm going on
going to jail now and I'm saying I I
said we shouldn't have done it I didn't
have anything to do with it I didn't
want to read any of the conversations on
her private device right I didn't want
to have anything
I didn't wanted to read it well that's a
good defense but future judge and jury
if you're watching this in the year 2080
400 whenever it is sincerely we had no
intention of de railing Lizzie's life
for sagres life it wasn't about that it
was just about a little bit of something
that we thought was entertaining and
interesting that we thought that the
people who listened to this podcast in
the year 2017 and Beyond would enjoy and
I really think you got to take into
account our intentions here in the fact
that we didn't really know what we were
getting ourselves into so please have
mercy and made the court have mercy on
our souls and for you present-day ear
biscuit ears hope that works leave a
comment on this YouTube video or this
SoundCloud stream or as an iTunes review
all of those things are valuable to us
and of course we'll be back next Monday
first thing with another ear of this yes
and if you're enjoying this on that this
is mythical YouTube channel and you
haven't subscribed yet do us a solid
subscribe
[Music]